what is Bard Bard is a large language
model it can also be referred to as a
conversational AI or chatbot trained to
be informative and comprehensive it's
trained on a massive amount of Text data
and is able to communicate and generate
human-like text in response to a wide
range of prompts and questions for
example Bard can provide summaries of
factual topics create stories help you
understand complex subjects and even
provide you step-by-step instructions to
build a birdhouse or even host your own
website you could ask Bard what types of
databases would work best for my current
project and make a list of comparisons
you could have it write a short story or
poem or song about your pet snake Frank
or even ask it questions like how do I
perform sentiment analysis with bigquery
ML how do I know all this well I just
asked barred what are you gonna ask Bard
first check out the link in our
description to see how you can start
using bard